who do you think is most helped and who
do you think is most hurt by the big
mitt quit most helped is Jeb Bush who
has the capacity now to rot lap lock up
the establishment donor class from coast
to coast and in the mid tier ii of the
country in a way he couldn't as long as
Romney was looming out there and if he
does that he could dominate fundraising
this year historically if you dominate
Republican fundraising the year before
the election you win I don't think
anybody is really hurt by this it opens
up a lot of space for possible
candidates and likely candidates it
gives everybody a chance now to say
they're going to glom on to some of that
Romney support yeah I think that you
know I agree with you bushes certainly
helped I think Christie has helped an
awful lot because it frees up a bunch of
donors that Romney might have gotten
into and I think it also helps Rubio and
Walker for the reasons that we were
talking about before the generational
argument the person i think is hurt here
is a guy like Rand Paul who for whom
I've always thought it would have been
good news to have a three-way battle of
the of the titans in the establishment
bracket Paul would have been in a better
position to consolidate the
anti-establishment brackets going to be
harder for him to do that if there's a
clear establishment hear a bird here's
why I think here's why I think this
helps Paul who is today the front-runner
in New Hampshire yeah with Romney in its
Romney with Romney out today I think
it's Rand Paul wow you think he's the
front-runner in New Hampshire Rand Paul
today I can't name anybody else i think
is more likely now over time Jeb Bush
let's see him go up there see if he can
build support but I think today Rand
Paul's the most likely one to win New
Hampshire I got to say if your eye to me
i got i'll go back to strengths that I i
mentioned Christie on the way and you
know I thought that Christie I mean
there's still like he's got a lot of
problems chris Christie I think going
into this but Romney accorded your
reporting was thinking about some of the
vetting that they did for him in the
vice presidential selection process of
2012 right there's a lot of problems for
chris Christie but for him I just I
can't help but think he's looking at all
those donors who MIT would have locked
up and now they are at least available
to him he's got to be super happy today
he's going to get a ton of them but Jeb
Bush is going to get more of them